hello everyone and welcome back to day
three of the opera euro rapid tournament
uh it's a
pretty crazy game between vivid and
magnus and uh before we check it out uh
for those of you who don't know
i have revealed the meaning of the name
agar matar it's in my previous video so
if you guys are interested in that do
check it out
but now that we have that out of the way
now we can now again
focus on what's most important and that
is of course the
the chess so uh without further ado
let's check out the game as it's quite a
nice one now with it has the white
pieces
and he opens with d4 and they're gonna
play a very very long theoretical line
uh that's well known in the chess world
so we're not gonna do well too much on
the opening
uh d4 we have d5 c4 and now e6 going
after
uh some sort of a queen's gambit decline
set up knight to f3 and
c6 we have the slav defense uh we have
e3 and the magnus ghost for f5 sort of a
stonewall uh defense here sort of a slav
stone wall
uh i think it's called the triangle
system but uh i mean
who knows whenever the pawns are like
this i i call this the stone wall
regardless of what white plays but
don't do that so f5 and now bishop to d3
uh but it continues developing knight to
f6
and now castles uh we have bishop to d6
both players just continue developing
pieces and b3 now preparing to
fianchetto the dark square bishop
to this nice diagonal we have queen to
e7 by magnus and
bishop to b2 uh we have castles and now
queen to c1 as the queen bishop battery
is
placed like this here that it wants to
play bishop to a3 and trade off some
pieces
so b6 by magnus and now bishop to a3 as
planned we have bishop to b7
and now uh video trades once we have
captured captures and
now queen to a3 immediately trying to
trade everything off so magnus of course
accepts this
he doesn't mind going into into an end
game queen captures
knight captures and now g6 so now just
strengthening all of the
uh squares at some point you might be
able to play something like knight d7
then maybe
you will have some breakthroughs with e5
or or c5
or well you know depending on what white
plays so here uh rook f the c1
and knight b to d7 and uh
there is uh there were some moves in the
database where bishop
to f1 was played but here we have c
captures on d5
and it is as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game
uh so c captures on the e5 we have e
captures on d5 by magnus
and now knight to c2 we have
a5 by magnus and now a4 uh we have
knights to e4 now
getting that knight to a beautiful
square here and g3 by white and now
king to g7 magnus starts improving the
position of the king
as he knows at some point he might
double rooks on the c file push c5 and
he wants his king to be as close as
possible to the action
uh we have knight seat e1 uh and now
rook f the c8 as planned and now comes
rook the c2 that it also wants to double
his works on the c
file and now magnus waits no longer and
he executes
c5 and here we have bishop to be
five by bit it a very nice move as the
knight on d7 is undefended so magnus
needs to tend to that he goes knight
back to f8
the knight will be shifted over to e6
and now just rook
a to c1 saying that okay my rooks are
now doubled here
you are more than welcome to go for c
captures on d4 but magnus says
there's no no rush i'm just going to
improve the position of my king a little
bit
but this is going to prove problematic
for magnus as vidit finds
knight to d3 and this is just extremely
dangerous now this knight can come
to e5 in the future and if the pawn
captures this knight can come to d4 so
the knights are most excellently placed
here
and here uh magnus uh it's not easy to
find a good move here for black probably
just improving the position with king to
e7
but magnus goes for uh c captures on d4
and this is uh problematic as now
vidit uh can achieve an almost winning
position
if he finds the correct idea but uh you
are
more than welcome to help him so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this elusive idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting
bishop to c6 also for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
as this is just a a monster move so
obviously you cannot ignore it as the
bishop here is under attack so let's see
what happens if
uh for example rook captures an uh or
rather bishop captures on c6 is played
we're just gonna trade here captures
captures captures
with check as the king is on f6 also
attacking the pawn here
and after king to f7 we're just gonna
recapture the pawn here and this is what
uh what i meant as
this knight is now a monster here this
knight is coming to e5 is going to be an
even bigger monster
and it's just going to be a pretty bad
position for black your b pawn is
hanging so if rook b8 you're just going
to go 95
check then the king moves then you can
do you you can do pretty much wherever
whatever here in black will have a very
very passive position
so after bishop to c6 you you do not
want to capture the bishop you could
however defend your bishop but it still
runs into the pretty much same idea just
captures and after captures captures and
captures there's also this check
so it's maybe a little bit better for
black as the b-pawn is already defended
but still after the king moves you're
just gonna recapture this play knight
the e5 check
and slowly mount the pressure uh but uh
it seems that vidi did not enjoy this
idea after c captures on d4 video just
recaptured he played knight captures on
d4
and now magnus was very much relieved uh
and he
immediately traded everything off rook
captures throughout captures and
rook the c8 we rook capture some c8
bishop captures and now
bishop to c6 going after the pawn here
uh so now magnus has to play knight to
c3 to defend it we have knight to c3
and now here vidit was up on time but it
had some five minutes and the clock
magnus had some three and a half minutes
but with it took all over three minutes
for his next move and it's not
uh not an easy position it's very hard
to find a move here you go knight f4 do
you go h4 do you go
whatever you play it's not easy verdit
uh decided to go for b4
but now magnus finds a very very tricky
line he plays
knight to e6 and now uh vidit
uh again has to decide what to do best
for vidit is just a trade captures
captures
or rather even capture on d4 first and
then after the knight is recaptured
capture on
on a5 but vidit did no such thing
after this knight to e6 he played knight
to b3
and now magnus has move that will really
pose
problems uh for vidic so uh feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea
and i know you know that uh
you know you you know what i want you to
find as
is the move we always discuss so feel
free to pause the video and try to spot
this idea
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations as
uh you you do not spot this idea unless
you're
an extremely great endgame player and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's knight to d8 now attacking the
bishop the pawn is defended and the
bishop doesn't have all that many
squares
so here uh bishop to a8 the only
available square for the bishop
and now comes bishop to a6 attacking the
knight here
and now the problem is if you block with
five then after bishop to b7
you have to trade and after captures
captures you're gonna have a problems
defending this a4 pawn
if knight to be too defending then uh
these guys are stuck here the
defending this guy stuck defending the
pawn and this here knight cannot move
because then the other knight attacks
the pawn
and it's just game over so this is not
good for vidit so with it instead goes
knight to f4 uh now with a double attack
on the
d5 pawn but now a captures on b4
we have knight captures on d5 this comes
with check knight captures bishop
captures and now
knight to e6 uh we have a5 by vitit and
here
magnus captures b captures on a5 knight
captures on a5 and now
knight to c5 so magnus grabs hold of the
b3 square with the knight and now it's
only a matter of shifting this bishop
over to gain control of the b3 square
and here
vidit plays f4 now giving magnus the
opportunity
to go for this maneuver uh for some
reason magnus goes bishop to b5 first it
seems like
it seems like uh magnus didn't uh get
this
idea right right from the start he
played bishop to b5 first and then he
wants to play this but it's basically
wasting a move but both of them were
extremely low on time
so maybe he just played bishop to b5 and
then he decided that he was going to go
for that either way
but okay king f2 by vedic we have bishop
to d7
and now e4 by bit it uh maybe king the
e2 a little bit better but
in such a time scramble who who can make
uh
what's what so here e4 by virit and now
f captures on e4
we have king to e3 as the e3 square has
now been vacated for the white king but
now
bishop to e6 and now you have problems
you can no longer capture
or rather recapture the pawn because if
knight captures king captures just b3
and if king to d3 now okay the king can
stop the pawn
but now the deadly king f5 and here the
knight
and the king has to have to tend to this
b3 pawn you're just gonna go all the way
to h3
and gobble up all of the pawns and it's
an easy game
so after bishop to e6 avidit said okay i
have to capture on e6 he played bishop
captures on e6 but now comes king
captures on e6 and the king to d4
but now just b3 so of course you cannot
capture
the knight if you capture b2 wins the
game there's no stopping the pawn
so here he played knights the c4 tried
to stop the pawn from reaching the b2
square but here magnus just played
knight to a4 and it was in this position
on mu 42 that vidiq resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
whatever you play
uh the this is coming of course the king
cannot even approach
and that's just it there's no move here
uh you can play you could go for knights
to d2
and then after b2 it seems like yes you
are stopping
uh b1 but what move can you play here
there really are
are none if you capture the pawn with
the king knight c3 check and uh both
squares are guarded for example
king goes after the knight you just
promote into a queen and now you have to
capture
captures captures black is just up a
piece so now whatever you do
you are losing this game so of course
the video knows this after knight to a
four now on move 42 if it is resigned
the game
and magnus takes a win in the first game
of the third day of the preliminaries
so it was a pretty crazy that it had a
an amazing position
but at a few points in the game he could
have continued better and
definitely ceased his uh opportunity
uh to to achieve much more than just the
loss here
after 42 moves but yeah i mean that's
chess it's a rapid game
uh you know you can always do better i
guess
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
mario british lioness janssen uh andrew
click uh jacopo segnini
and jason finger for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the third day
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day